I forgot I forgot the why I forgot Lee
why how how I do this
leave your in treasonous ready pros
might see a figurine render Wow
so cool I love Maya actually I do that
son thing so actually that should be on
mine using the Drake format using the
team transform at because they are stuck
at sixteen point five million donate
three donate or we could just go with my
idea of bulk buying choice come on we
got sixteen who says charity can't they
just give us four million for free
please we bought 1650 my place in Japan
was rub they took all our stuff
epic I'll never forget that about eggs
where is this from is that Full Metal
Alchemist oh god someone's gonna be the
first thing to ever be cuter than baby
Groot must have been like you know what
I may have been a little harsh on baby
Yoda and I'm looking forward to look at
Mandalorian I just have Disney PTSD okay
sue me they don't sue me Disney Babji
fortnight minecraft terraria that is so
cute I ship it so hard Farrah
Diana I kiss on the world now runs on
video game logic what's the first thing
you do look at my stats to find out what
the [ __ ] is wrong in telogen -5 I knew
it
P P 10 huh baby 10 that's really good
that's slightly above average I knew it
science you can't hear picture me
intellectual alright let's see if I can
hear it
what can years goddamnit
minecraft also tried to area terraria
also toy maker Thank You Trey I ship it
I ship it I
to [ __ ] Joker just became meme of
October 2019 I agree Hey look at that
well done well done Joker
congratulations
it's December Jesus Christ hey gamers so
today was the two-year anniversary of me
getting out of rehab after getting
paralyzed for two months learning how to
walk again
congratulations I know he probably won't
see this but I can't thank him enough
for having me through the hard times oh
here's a picture of me in pizza Dennis
oh well done
oh maybe though that's amazing I knew it
the only reason people watch my videos
is because they literally have no other
choice I knew it
I'm quitting YouTube here's why no one
cares be like wetness day for 50 99
Thursday for $15.99 Black Friday that's
a great freakin price dude stinks I'm
making strong shout here we made a team
trees donation stand what that's awesome
well done well done I'll donate finding
out I should do a live stream to get the
final push for team trees for million
easy easy
yeah let's do that that's got to be the
best pirate I have ever seen so it would
seem how dad run flash that's not even a
front play that's a barrel roll they did
a Swedish backflip but then they hit an
iceberg brah but she just hate when you
do a sweet ass backflip and hit an
iceberg
i recreated felix old house in minecraft
that's so weird oh my god pity pies
stairs in Minecraft those stairs served
no purpose I would never walk up those
stairs hated those stairs science you
guys liked my last coin a lot here's
another one friend laser cutting Felix
on her school's laser engraver will not
get you into her why me someone went
against words and made thing happened
Felix putting his legs on before making
any age I've been exposed very well no
more songs for you are you expert in
English yes then answer me one question
okay a mother beats up her daughter
because she was drunk that way who was
drunk
[Laughter]
well-played big brain big brain energy I
like that
six-year-old me thinking that I'm still
a kid a six-year-old calling me sir
that relatable moment plants vs. zombies
500,000 trees I'm in the spirit of
Festivus plants vs. zombies donated is
that it that's also is that that's why
it's 16.5 my brother did spend all his
birthday money that's great
official boy very nice
fillings mom shows onion Felix no Felix
mom it's chicken Felix you stand up a
bit I'm in let me get that chick yeah
this is so good num num num it tastes
stop YouTube confirms PewDiePie is in
the YouTube rewind 2019
that is like button every 19 year old
not yet Ferb not yet we will wait oh
yeah I wonder what are we gonna get this
year huh if lovely puns is not in a
youtube rewind
did three one even happen at all one
really likes and I'll buy reddit and
reveal how the Karma system works what
is karma what is this
I built Joker stairs in Terraria what
the hell are these why are they teased
yeah I knew it
Jaden almost fell out of her chair
life's rewind no one asked if she's okay
you okay Jaden there you doing okay if
my chair doesn't make it in rewind this
year then watch the point what's
beautified when he sees an animal in
Minecraft Oh Jo Jo gorgeous pewdiepie
when it sees an animal in terror you
help advise my craft video starts how
they end
yeah what we kissed on PD PI stars
that's so romantic
oh my god and it's two boys that's so
sweet
and gay ninja wants to be remembered as
one of the greatest gamers ever okay
people who laugh at me but don't app the
little red tree please call me
the devil oh my god oh my god
they posted it they posted the unedited
oh they unedited version oh that guy's I
have really long arms they go up all the
way here Loki I look kind of cute if I'm
short
what a fine Photoshop instead I'm just
shoving my arm in his ass
if Korean pop is kpop then Chinese rap
is crap
oh God Chinese read the crap that is the
ultimate insult Oh God
hey look it's always it the best gamer I
like ninja don't get me wrong I'll never
understand how college and NFL football
teams allowed kickers that just based
kicks I feel like there has to be rules
of kickers in the USA that won't miss
simple kicks or snappers that won't mess
a snap I don't know man seemed so silly
would love opinion on this I encourage
opinions please tell me I know this is
controversial but like come on guys fill
me in I'll never understand how Pro for
my player just miss shots I feel like
there has to be porters of pro players
who can't just click on their heads and
hit every shot with 100% accuracy just
seemed so silly I don't understand how
memes can just not be funny all of them
the thing about this is the response
like and there's a I think he responded
to this one
he thermos ninya doesn't understand what
you can't miss huh here it is here this
this is what ruin it for me cuz like
yeah yeah sometimes I tweet them to
alright that's fine but then he double
down on it this is reply ever for that
requires movement there are not position
in fortnight okay a kickers job is
literally to kick horrible analogy like
this I love this one but the final kind
of embarrassing kind of embarrassing for
you there little boy
why would it be embarrassing for a
random stranger to tweet at you it's
like he's projecting what he said is
kind of embarrassing on to someone else
and he makes no sense at all
names yet my man come on stop get some
help
I think ninja has potential to be great
this gamer okay don't get me wrong but
like stop trying so hard you can have
that as a goal without shoving it into
people's faces
Friday British friend I lost 100 pounds
fat American friend I lost hundred
pounds oh I got it bro
I'm currently selling about her [ __ ] on
eBay and I'm like okay that's 40 pounds
what this that would Google a poot
saying my peepee small me knowing my
peep is still longer than frogs exist
biology students why do they do that to
frogs
that's so mean I don't need to see there
are nothing to me I don't need to see it
I know school otherwise because more
trees equals less zombies and the spirit
of Festivus we're planting 500,000 trees
with game trees well maybe I don't want
to be the bad guy anymore maybe not
maybe not but you still did all those
horrible things he and I cannot forgive
unless you pay me ah unless you pay me a
Lambo Lamborghini I could get the friend
need for speed partner up what's up Nick
I am here and game Need for Speed game
that's my sales pitch hit me up here we
used to collab come on what happened me
watching pills as a nine-year-old me
watching pills as a 19 year old that is
d you mean 99 year old you look you
don't look so good that Yoda blood
acquires its red color from sibling
hamburg Lubin and through the protein
gamma burger building communism
communism isn't it epic how you can joke
about communism but not the other bad
things if people just explained to me
long ago do you know how much my sister
thousand Instagram followers my brothers
hundred Twitter followers my one Reddit
follower
damn that's a nuke I'm ready to take
right up my balls what if you wanted to
show you're friendly but God said sticky
key I got it
minecraft better and then they made me
lie my laughs will be my testimony when
you can't buy the sukkah black merch
because your parents are russian yet
sadly no system
go show pills and Mises in love right
now ah hangers guys that's awesome
show Mars hasn't lost she deserves it
right there might see a nice message I
had nothing stolen I had books and gym
equipment for some reason they didn't
one thing but I had like Calvin and I
had Vette mounts and they didn't take it
like $300 shredder bro like why if he
took it I'd be like they have I respect
that I respect that
hey pits I've been eating Swedish
meatballs in IKEA with your merch it
doesn't get more Swedish than this epic
that's a really young 19 year old how
about that what I see with my cats have
you ever taken a photo of yourself when
you're hunched over it is probably the
least appealing thing you could ever do
and now I have to feel like I have to
demonstrate well that was a completely
worthless segment how old is Vsauce 33
years how long does so so there's only
one man who can find the thief of
pewdiepies house B man did it
plot twist he's the one that broke in
the house whenever I joke about it I get
people like how can you joke about that
let me feel whatever I want terraria is
number one training for gaming on
YouTube thanks to Peter PI thanks for
the shoutout
terraria you're awesome joker tree oh
that did not make me laugh wow I am
pathetic
remember rock this is him now feel all
get damn he's old respect the grind man
study concludes bigger than average PP
is a disability and
it's associated with low capacity so
really when Peter says small peepee he
says big brain ultimate plot waist
oh my god ha I've been to 69 420 futures
and how many of those did we hit 20
million trees we have to do it gamers we
have to do it ah donate repos repos
Reapers Reapers I will say this I am
proud of how the subreddit this let it
be the worst subreddit of all time ninja
wants to be the greatest gamer I want
the shittiest subreddit petition to have
Felix eat hot wings on hot ones and get
INRI by Sean Evans that'd be epic too
bad I don't leave my house that's an
awfully hot coffee pot America has
Thanksgiving Europe I think I I slept
through Thanksgiving because I didn't
see any memes I didn't see nothing and
it was great dad I'm hungry
hi hungry I'm dad funny but seriously
I'm really hungry I really hungry I bet
aren't you hungry no I'm not hungry
hi not hungry I'm your ha ha ha ha brah
that's good that's good upload this if
you have big PP Phi nights at freddys
people now people in 2014 how about
Tweety pie in 2015 ok
everyone was so mad at me for not like
in those garbage games I'm a grown man
I'm a big adult I can do this push the
meme to the sub P B small B P smart
oh no smoke P P so I found a door in a
tree trunk and it was full of a pile of
money and a single rug so you broke into
this house you broke into these this is
disgusting despicable small PP whoever
made so I had to do a presentation on
someone I respect and oh who is it what
did you do I hope you got an a I'm gonna
say it big P P
this one gets a big P P people who
passed know not November nothing blue
balls
congrat
you got blue balls there are two ways to
react someone broke into our house they
took all our stuff and pink happy
I just watched drew Grodin's video on
this on that family it's so funny
listen you're not a year real youtuber
unless you monetize bad things that
happen to you I told my dad to chill and
he said I am chill and I said I thought
you were dad
hi dad joke my dad I am the revolution
hello revolution I'm dad a bitter defeat
yes donating well done credit where
credit is due
eh net worth is twenty two point nine
billion people live when Jeff Bezos
donated 100 million I was like your net
worth is pretty blue so therefore a
hundred million doesn't mean anything oh
yeah well ei should have donated 1
billion at least stop I want to pinch me
this is unlicensed merged that makes me
angry
we gamers rise up when pity pot likes
her meme you obtained a bottle of PP up
Pia Pia you wanna see something hot sure
lava pretty hot right yeah I guess well
that love us 5 seconds old have fun in
jail when your salad keeps making jokes
so good where did you fight all these
did I make all those faces damn I got a
lot of places
honestly the song isn't good if it
repeats a word over and over again thank
you for being a stone dead that's ninja
damn we got Jack 2 in the house that's
sick
walking running sprinting trying to find
where you died in the cave before your
items do spawn this is the most
relatable I don't get it we all know eel
and musk is just Hank Scorpio Gillen
knows it's true just because he has a
flamethrower and I have a flamethrower
doesn't mean ok fine I hope minecraft
veteran terraria veterans PD I'm trying
I've been really enjoying terraria it's
a really good game my place in Japan was
robbed they took all that stuff the
random Japanese 9 general who just
robbed a random person's house I'm gonna
go ahead and say it person who rubbed my
house
BP small that's right I didn't want to
go there but I did and
don't even give a break about it by the
merch so I can buy back all the stuff
that I I didn't lose that would be epic
thank you guys for watching this video
if you enjoyed smash alike and download
pretty price pick something like it's a
fun game look it's a game you are
entering a new era where you shall crash
they own
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne where T is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices
you